hey player are you doing hey can I make
a request sure man what're you looking
for a man
hook a brother up with them Oh oh yeah a
word okay what you looking for a biggie
Tupac biggie Tupac come on man that's
too new I'm talking about that
Oh school man you know what I'm talking
about oh I thought I did it was like uh
wu-tang clan wu-tang clan oh okay well
uh how old you looking for a man with
NWA and W ay come on man I look like a
kid out there talking about the ends of
your egg fo shizzle my nizzle Kris Kross
applesauce who's the boss Tony Danza at
a loss I don't know it all right
I'm talking about that Oh school okay
you know what that's my bad old man all
right we gonna take you back all right
i'ma bust out some Run DMC for you right
now
Run DMC Run DMC you wouldn't want to be
a onomatopoeia grab a donkey by the toe
give him gonorrhea I don't know it all
right all I know it's on old school if
you can't give it to me you can't give
the ball man Run DMC is old school
what can you name a group you the DJ man
are you trying to tell you how to do
your job Grandmaster Flash
man Grandmaster Flash you sound like a
kid yourself talking about Grandmaster
Flash to the own Bob the
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo just don't stop the
boogie to the bang bang boogie to
upchuck wah people song about upchuck
Sugar Hill Gang brother how we end up in
Candyland what man
if you want some old school then you
come back here and find it yourself I'm
going on break get myself back here
right in here see what's going on back
here what we got will cap nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope no now we talked him
[Applause]
[Music]
you